oh I don't know what we're watching here
I'm not 100% sure I just loaded up the
game and apparently there's an epilepsy
warning so be careful about that lots of
flashing colors
help
okay I'm always down to help Bonjour
Bonjour a whoa ah right
hello everybody welcome to puss I think
I'm supposed to click-and-drag yeah okay
everybody this is um this is a game that
I don't think I'm going to be able to
explain so this is uh this is puss puss
is do you remember that do you remember
that a maze game from a long time ago
that was a prank that when you got close
to the end it just ended up jump scaring
you well that's like that game expanded
into a full game as far as I know okay
world complete we are going to show you
we're gonna show me what you're gonna
show me a good time you're gonna show me
how to learn to hate myself as many
things that games tried to teach me
throughout this experience oh I got some
things I guess I get some more lives
from when I eventually screw this all up
I don't like that this is going towards
a pentagram and also oh oh no it's like
a mixture of the world's hardest game oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh my corpse all my corpulent corpse
oh my splatter corpse oh goodness gravy
can I collect any of that nope that's
just that's his gun he's a straight-up
corpsey corpse okay Wow okay did it
something beautiful
we're gonna show me something beautiful
is that what you're gonna show me I
don't believe it but oh ye I'm sorry I
hi Duchamp
okay Duchamp I don't know if there was
something that was supposed to be there
is there a reason that there were two of
those or is it just hi oh yeah that's
okay all right well I don't like the way
those cats are staring at me but yeah
yeah yay where is this going it where
are you taking me
oh I don't know I think I did that okay
oh I know I need to go around of course
it makes so much sense now I don't like
the cries of the cats in the back I
don't like anything about this I got so
many questions about what the hell has
happened is that potatoes why is it
raining potatoes on Mother Mary
[ __ ] that was right off the bat no
stupid of me right off the bad boy bad
boy okay here we go here we go here we
go oh no here we don't go we're not
going all we're going we're going okay
so I just got to find the safety zones
and once I find the safety zones I am
good to go
oh it's a checkpoint oh yeah good thing
I got such great hand-eye coordination
this is great everything's fine
everything's fine about this this is
great oh my god oh I don't like you
moving like that oh yeah hey oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] sorry
no oh this ins this one's gonna be a
little tough oh I just have so why
closes the closes this is closes like a
shop it closes why have you closed your
doors to the ball Frick god damn it I'm
gonna run
lives Oh tits I'm gonna run out of lives
just gotta be patient the name of the
game is patience
okay wait here we go here's my chance oh
no oh my god Go Go oh god oh god oh god
oh well that was more stressful than I
ever wanted okay but good I'm alive ins
that I can keep going okay I'm almost to
the pentagram that's got to be good one
eye here
Frogger we playing Frogger here is that
what we's do blink it's locked the
button in Mario once you press it some
happens not sure do I need to go back do
I need to go I am fine I am fine I am
fine taking the second bus
I am fine got it nailing this super hard
that's too fast thank you for the bigger
boat uh I made it
Hey visit the steam group I don't like
that that kid doesn't have a lower half
that's not good all right Bo what is
happening I am so with me questions
hello why does it keep getting more
insane every time I turn a corner every
new level is just a new level of a
sanity what is happening what's
happening - plus I guess I'll stop okay
thank you you are so kind
no hard pass this is that peer pressure
I was warned about these are the drugs
how's it now I don't like the sound of
sacrifice that sounds like it might be
me
[Music]
don't bless us bless you did you sneeze
oh you were the sacrifice oh oh I can't
move there we go oh whoa wait stop how
can I'm not I don't get it okay
that was unfortunate I was trying to not
die and then I'm dying okay I'm good at
bullet hell's I know I'm good at these
okay all right all right just gotta do I
don't like that too where oh wow
stop it you Oh oh that's not good oh oh
[ __ ] sneeze sneeze oh there we go
pow okay one more one more one more and
I'm out I'm out baby okay pal oh [ __ ]
guy you scratched up to hell him back
yeah yeah you don't yeah yeah it wasn't
one half your health yeah what are you
gonna do about nothing oh okay all that
I don't like to look at that oh my god
Cerberus Oh who's a big boy who's who's
uh [ __ ] Oh who's uh who's our bigger
Rick oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god
ah [ __ ] oh you have so many eyes stop
look I'm trying oh my god oh my god oh
my god I got two lives left I'm gonna
concentrate like I've never concentrated
before oh [ __ ] ah well Teddy sprinkles
ah well there goes me then
oh [ __ ] I gotta do it again alright I'll
be this is different hey hi okay did
that whoa uh uh-huh
okay sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry that's my
bad I this is new all I can do in
response is cry if I just vomit at
random
oh this idiot oh this is isn't this
isn't this the scary maze isn't it isn't
this it if I remember correctly ye
come on okay he was expecting a jump
scare but no oh my god is getting
weirder every single time
damn it damn it god damn it
okay got that here we go here we go here
we go here we go
easy peasy easy squeeze me oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] I got to do this damn it I'm going
oh I made it oh my god I mean it I can't
believe I made it okay there we go there
we go here we go come on scooch get
longer get longer stronger what the hell
what
oh [ __ ] oh my god this one hurts my eyes
so badly I feel I can feel my brain
melting out of my ears I am going to die
oh you gotta I see you gotta stay on
this button hope hope hope hope there we
go
okay I probably got no points from that
which means I got no lives but whatever
all right I just need to get enough
Livesay when I go back it's good okay I
don't know I don't know I don't like the
way these things are looking at me I
don't know okay alrighty then oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy why you
know when I first went through this the
levels weren't this hard BAM oh my god
it takes so much focus this is like the
most focused I ever have to be in my
life oh my god okay here we go oh hey
how's it going in there I don't know
what that oh boy die hurt Oh God
I can't see anything kind of makes it
difficult oh I think I saw that was
gonna be yeah it's gonna it's gonna
gloss right over me hurry hurry hurry
hurry
oh all right here we go again here we go
here we go here we go let's do this
sacrifice of blood okay if I could just
not lose 10 lives right off the bat I
think I'll be perfectly happy all right
you scrappy [ __ ] all right come back to
me come ere give me the power oh there
he goes he's doing his thing oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] ah lucky lucky me Oh give
me that pow
give me it whoa there oh that was a god
stop give me a goddamn second okay here
we go
I'm really gonna wham him I'm ready
digging scratch
oh yeah more than half more than half on
that one with half on that one baby I
got nine lives left I'm a cat that's how
many lives we have that is pretty
typical and everything that I was
talking about all right I'm gonna get
these you're gonna see just how fricked
you are excuse my language
oh wow okay okay
can I just get my bearings are you
[ __ ] with me how in the [ __ ] is that
fair oh my god are you fricking with me
one life left
aah aah are you kidding me are you
kidding me how is that fair how is that
fair that's [ __ ] up that is [ __ ] up
that's [ __ ] up all right [ __ ] that and
[ __ ] you oh well this is super sexual
I'm not sure I'm I'm not sure I'm liking
this you just oh just really not feeling
it you know yeah but at least I'm there
and I got a lot of lives I got a lot of
lives and I got a new best score this is
gonna be great this is gonna he's gonna
turn out great this time I got 20 lives
20 no way I could lose all those lives
there's no way all right
your ass is grass this time douche hole
you're ready for a face full of Puss cuz
I'm coming for you well I'm uh oh you
almost got me that time with the same
old grabby mechanics I'm gonna get you
all Mogi you ow [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
that is the least fair thing ever okay
here we go I'm ready oh yeah oh how do
you like them apples huh how do you like
them apples huh yeah not so good not so
tasty apples huh not so good apples
apples were a little rotten I got 17
lives and a whole lot of [ __ ] and you
got a whole lot too bit just wait you
wait buddy bow oh just you wait oh you
think I think that you think that you
just you gonna be free huh you think
that you did there weren't gonna be
repercussions
for what you did to me huh oh [ __ ] okay
Oh [ __ ]
my one more one more where is it where
is it where is it where's my pal there
isn't my pal
there's my pal here we go all right I'm
gonna really give it to you ooh ooh
you're gonna get it oh oh you got some
more eyes for me to scratch [ __ ] get
scratched oh my hand is Grand Baie oh
yeah it's right yeah it's right yes oh
yeah I'll [ __ ] you I'll [ __ ] you give
[ __ ]
yes this [ __ ] ain't so easy is it yes
right yeah it's right yeah it's right
give me this right give me those
give me those oh [ __ ] oh that cat has a
moustache a hello oh it is a long time
since the heroes were last here the
euros you say I love that moustache have
you no you know no kidding I've noticed
that right right okay all right gotcha
[Music]
yeah uh all the keys and free the
prisoners they will help you get to the
beasts lair and attack it there
uh yeah what was your name you didn't
even tell me your name sir a mr.
mustache I I just was going for a walk I
took a wrong turn somewhere I just want
to go home dive happened some difficulty
now understanding why did you lose them
just wouldn't a janitor have the copies
okay all right whoa whoa I like a four
four sounds good
entering counter world eight four four
why is it full of teeth
why is four full of teeth wow that got
munched whoa hey why is it full of teeth
this isn't that something's not right
about this [ __ ] just gonna point it out
some ain't so right where is it full of
teeth why was a unicorn oh no [ __ ]
yeah been slapped in the face oh my god
this isn't this isn't that complicated
but his goblin gated I got no idea who's
talking to me why are you why are you
talking to me
[Music]
good okay okay
made it oh my god this this is the only
hell there's only hell hell this is just
Oh amen amen are you shooting Sarabhai
hut up you're next I wanna go home I
wanna go home
oh my god alright wrap around the wrap
around the end and any whinny I whinny
yes I do
we're only halfway through this
wonderful counter war I don't like I
don't like I don't like I don't like I
don't like I don't like you don't do
that you don't do that to me oh [ __ ] oh
oh okay we're fine
okay this makes sense uh-huh okay I see
this makes just so much sense okay here
we go
boop boop tit no you're not gonna get me
no you're gonna get me oh you're not
gonna get me this time they'll watch
this maneuver [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I
wanna get watched dis maneuver
what the [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] oh it's it's
better just get looked at oh oh oh what
a thumping beat oh that's a heartbeat
never mind not a thumping beat I wasn't
thinkin there was gonna be
got it nailed it I'm good I'm great
give me those lives okay let's see what
else we got in store oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
ah we're fine it's totally fine
easy Oh like it was nothing I'm getting
good at this I'm getting so good there's
no way that I can ever not be good and
it's like everyone every corners oh it's
new madness around every corner it's new
madness oh boy
Oh [ __ ] oh god damn it oh I wasn't dead
there there there
[ __ ] god damn it oh no no no oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] me oh god holy [ __ ] this is hard
how how what what the [ __ ] what the 500
no none of that none of that none of
that the [ __ ] with the [ __ ] hoga oh oh
that I don't like any of that that's
some [ __ ] right there I'm getting
you I understand you now oh I can't see
don't do that I can't see don't let oh I
can't see hang on hang on hang on hang
on oh there we go okay well we did that
I don't know I got 10 lives 11 12 13 14
okay what's that oh I see oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] me [ __ ] doc ock there's a lot of
corpses I just noticed there's a lot of
corpses in that hallway there's a lot of
corpses not my corpse is not not mine
the other corpses that aren't mine not
sure where they came from but uh not
[ __ ] made it oh [ __ ] no no the save god
[ __ ] guy hit the save oh hey trouble
getting ahead derp
no I'm fine [ __ ] well good luck to you
oh I guess I should have I guess I could
have asked for help
oh my god ah I made it I've only got
like eight how many left ten I've had
ten lives okay let's see what that would
see what's up let's just see what's up
okay don't look so bad it don't look so
bad it don't look so bad don't look so
bad it's not so bad it's not not so bad
oh ye okay button oh oh oh it's bad
oh hey no no no no no oh oh oh oh what
do I do
oh here comes the money free money okay
I got some pals I think oh okay I get it
I think I get it I don't know what the
limits of my flexibility are here but I
think I get it oh ow [ __ ] oh oh it's a
surreal nightmare can I please just get
a winning I know for I don't know how
slots really work so it's just like
fruit I guess can I get some you know
pal okay there's a POW give me that
power I want that no I it was supposed
to be a pal
yeah wild oh oh oh get zapped [ __ ] get
zapped oh [ __ ] how's this I think house
yes yes pals give me the POW oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] come on come on give me no you [ __ ]
there we go there we go there we go
Zappa barbra Zappa Baba Zappa Baba's
appabob azapa baba oh yeah oh yeah oh
[ __ ] no breaking the slot machine uh-uh
I don't know wasn't me
I didn't do it four lives left I can do
this I can do this
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] how did how
the [ __ ] ja how the [ __ ] am I missing
there we go
wild zaps zappity zu zappity Zeebo
Sam put us up okay I need one more card
damn it okay there we go oh baby oh baby
oh baby oh baby no biri biri biri Oberer
whoa okay super red hot jackpot I'll
take it I don't know what that means
whoo big win okay sure
oh [ __ ] oh well oh oh god oh god oh god
no okay
I'll keep my eyes oh [ __ ] [ __ ] aah oh my
god oh my god oh my god one life left
oh my god I thought I was so close no I
was right there god dammit oh [ __ ] me oh
god oh I'm so heartbroken I'm so
heartbroken I'm so broken okay here we
go
nine lives all that I really need you
know all that I ever really needed here
comes some money okay sure yeah okay
here we go six lives plenty of PAL
plenty of room to pass ain't gonna see
nothing coming their way they know they
know they're done they dunzo you're done
you're done zou okay we go get rekt get
shrek rekt get rekt come on whoa there
we go god damn hug time oh [ __ ] doves
that's weird
oh okay oh Jesus Halla hey what's up
how's it going
[Laughter]
it's not gonna be geez this is gonna be
cat Jesus or something no Jesus buddy
hey do it God's okay all right Linda
that's a thing that happened
Wow yeah okay all right wow that's um
yeah that's Wow okay Wow Wow Wow a lot
of lives there good for me I can't wait
to waste them all right only five more
to go let's blast through these bad boys
oh [ __ ] well oh there goes my protection
that I just add oh wait is that like a
special buffer I get it oh I get that at
the beginning of the world oh that's the
bad okay I didn't know that was the bad
I get it so that's like a shield that
probably gives me one free death are ye
oh [ __ ] god damn it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
yep oh come on I was so there there we
go easy-peasy should have been easy
peasy I've got this okay I'm gonna blast
through
oh boy a game of snake huh
ie ah come on [ __ ] [ __ ] oh that's the
slam shut okay that's stupid come on
please this real [ __ ] game uh yeah
yeah no you tricked me
ah [ __ ] you oh wait oh god damn
oh you yam oh you oh you yam oh you oh
you you did trick me you did trick me
you did that intentionally ah [ __ ] you
I'm gonna get through one of these with
my shield intact
alright so that goes there a lot of
curve ease I don't like the curve ease
but I can do it
[Music]
easy with shield intact with shield
intact does that give me like a bonus
life or something or maybe he's just us
save okay
again corpses why well [ __ ] me shoot oh
that's weird
owl
[ __ ] okay oh [ __ ] me
okay got that weirdly oh oh I see oh no
oh no okay well that was easy
okay I thought it was gonna be much much
much more difficult but okay I'll take
it okay
this is bizarre oh never mind
okay well I'll just squander that that's
how I roll I just squander all my
opportunities I think I see oh there is
there's a small window of opportunity
when these guys go by yeah got it
okay that was I don't know if that was
worth waiting but I got it oh come on
[ __ ] oh god damn it ah [ __ ] me in the
butt no [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] oh god okay well
here we go yep there I am okay well I
didn't even make it to the boss that
time oh [ __ ]
well [ __ ] there I go I am lay dead
mmm that's bizarre I don't like that
that's not good
well I don't know what that's all about
but okay oh I see oh I see oh well [ __ ]
god damn it Oh what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] I was through that god damn it god
[ __ ] damn it come on I was through it
[Music]
close okay your Commodore BOSU I don't
know what the boss it do you okay a key
right there is so easy it's like I could
just go grab it which I will I'm gonna
go grab it
I like these space invaders they're nice
oh oh the mothership Oh
oh no my key you bastard why can't I get
through here there we go I'm gonna get
you oh just you wait oh I'm coming to
get you oh you were gonna be gone
hey wait was I not supposed to get oh
[ __ ] I don't know what I just got but I
got it come on oh oh okay all right
oh oh it's it's real it's real this so
that's why it was space invader okay no
pause this time no scat cat cats cat
scratches whoa that's what that do oh
sure
oh why am i hitting oh do you have
ovaries are you big flying vagina I just
realized that I don't often have time to
look at you when I'm fighting these
battles so uh yeah you're a big floaty
vagina ain't ya that's that's fun that's
oh [ __ ] yeah I'm hitting you in your
quad ovaries okay yeah that's your a big
vagina
alright mothership I know that can't be
the end of it so come on yeah yeah I
knew whoa whoa wait whoa whoa oh I see
how you be okay I see trying to chase me
huh not gonna happen
where am i with a what the [ __ ] where am
i oh Sh where am I what the where was I
okay I guess I won I couldn't move
all right well fine then you just ate up
some of my lives but at least I got the
key seize the moment little cats all
right I will
oh don't worry don't worry I will okay
thank you
moving on I don't know what the unicorn
gives me if it does give me anything
which I would assume it does seems like
that would be the oh my god hello seems
like that would be the logical thing
right each of these things gives me a
special power that's gonna help me
through the rest of the game you know
man these levels are super weird I was
in the underworld the overworld the
outer world a lot of war oh [ __ ] well
now is dumb hey but at least it kept the
progress of the level that's that's
awfully kind of it come on I know [ __ ]
off these guys are trying my patience oh
my god I know what the [ __ ] oh boy
damn it oh I thought I could make it
okay I get it
wait no I don't get it hang on wait a
second just that easy huh it was an
illusion to do the other stuff it was a
stupid runaround
it was a fool's errand then I was the
fool oh boy
ow why [ __ ]
I was there
[ __ ] you whatever whatever you know what
whatever I don't get in whatever it's
fine whatever whatever this duh oh this
level I've already done this level I
know I know this one
well I died anyway Wow wouldn't you know
that mmm that's fascinating
it seems pretty tame so far except for
me being an idiot of course but what
else is new there ah I see I see I see
the rush oh come on I was right there I
was right there made no sense that I got
killed there but then again with me
anything is possible
okay eggs wha eggs
oh boy eggs okay eggs eggs huh okay eggs
eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs exit
I don't know why eggs but you know what
I'm not questioning it it's just eggs
and eggs or what it is how am I supposed
to get past these eggs just like that
huh just like that
okay let's go the long way around
thought of egg go to end my eggs hey
okay egg done all right now on to boss I
got 12 lives that should be more than
enough to beat a boss I can do all the
rest in a row because I'm so goddamn
good at this site read these levels I
got by attaboy mother [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh we're flying oh we're in some kind of
a hell but uh oh ah I don't like that
nope don't like that at all
don't like nope don't like that no I do
not like that yeah
to mannequin esque it's not good nope
don't zoom in now don't zoom in do not
zoom in on that hell oh okay
I'm markiplier yeah
I don't know man I want to go home point
at the key point in Icarus helmet Icarus
okay oh I'm sure I will
there I go paying for it oh wow that's
not cool okay ah god oh god oh my god
that is awful
what am I supposed to do how why good
God frickin oh my god are you kidding me
what the hell okay I what am I supposed
to do what am I supposed to do you are
not giving me any clear [ __ ]
directions there's no direction oh my
god that one life left 12 lives down to
one just like that apparently [ __ ]
I'm so mad I'm so mad this is do a
different one [ __ ] you the underworld I
swear we've been in the underworld why
the [ __ ] are you kidding me what the
[ __ ] I was right there god damn it
there's sometimes this weird thing we're
crossing over between platforms just
doesn't work sometimes that's so stupid
[ __ ]
goddamnit oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god [ __ ] in
[ __ ] oh my god are you [ __ ] kidding
me come on I've died doing that every
time at the beginning of this goddamn
level why am I not it oh my [ __ ] god
oh oh my [ __ ] god
if why why am i I'm getting it there
every [ __ ] time every it's so easy
there but here no here impossible for
some [ __ ] reason why what the [ __ ]
why why that should not be it should not
be every [ __ ] of lost seven [ __ ]
lives seven [ __ ] lives on that one
[ __ ] level don't you [ __ ] this is
so stupid it's so [ __ ] stupid
god [ __ ] damn this game that's so
ridiculously stupid this suit makes no
sense that made no sense what the [ __ ]
here we go fast as the light okay
made it Oh made it made it made it made
it made it two more lives that's not
enough that's I just want to be very
clear not enough that's not enough live
shrimp okay
why shrimp why why shrimp where am I
supposed to go am I just supposed to
make my way through somehow no boy there
we go
okay shrimp yeah okay yeah shrimp
alright this is really silly I don't
understand you but okay
oh [ __ ] oh sorry shrimp the shrimp's
grade here ah no I made it wow are those
shrimps on poles pole dancing shrimp
hello hi how are you well that's too bad
[Music]
point at the key it's a key yeah okay
how about wait I got I got a bunch of
those okay sorry I don't not in my face
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay okay
[ __ ]
ah well [ __ ] me then oh boy why not net
why now Jesus Christ a gnat really a
gnat is going to try to get in my face
right now oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god I've got it ah [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
where am i where am I here
ah [ __ ] god damn it oh god oh [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] oh my god please just let me
finish this
[ __ ]
it's about to explode get on my back oh
oh no oh no oh no oh no no oh God I
wasn't able to even touch it God it
wasn't able to control it that's so
[ __ ] stupid God [ __ ] entering the
inner world No
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh my
god
oh well [ __ ] my god [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that no I don't want
to restart the [ __ ] game just get me
out of this goddamn world [ __ ] this job
I don't care it says let me restart I'm
not gonna go into that seven lives down
on the second [ __ ] level no I don't
want to go why not why I can go back I
don't want to [ __ ] off oh god now I have
to die again over and over over and
[ __ ] over [ __ ] over and over again
[ __ ] over and over again [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god okay
no [ __ ] off
god damn it oh my god you get higher
points and therefore more lives if
you're flawless
multiple times in a row and of course it
just had if I didn't want this
[ __ ] oh boy of course what the
[ __ ] oh my god
three god damn it I'm suing so good and
I go into this with four [ __ ] lives
oh never mind three let's make it now
four vote yes what the [ __ ]
there's no point in this there's no
[ __ ] point
I'm getting so mad I'm so [ __ ] mad
here we go
now I have lives I have 18 lives this
one's hard as [ __ ] but I still should be
able to get through it hmm No
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
I wasn't even [ __ ] or whatever
you know what whatever I'm done trying
to ask how my goddamn sense
ah come on come on
Jesus stop going exactly where I can go
there she is 12 lives at least six lives
already Jesus okay here we go here we go
it's about to explode
get on my back yeah whatever
no no let me control it [ __ ] you God
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] it won't let me control it
what the [ __ ] is the point yeah I made
it I know I made it that's great that I
made it but it wouldn't let me
I could not [ __ ] move it I click I
move I click I [ __ ] move that's fine
see I can't move my mouse now it does
that it does that it locks my [ __ ]
mouse
god
okay good great we got another one
[ __ ] wonderful
[ __ ]
no I did it again God five buck
hahahahaha
alright here we go on to this boss with
plenty of lives eighteen that's a good
number of lives oh yeah this guy [ __ ] he
squashed my life super hard though I had
tons of life's going into him and I
still couldn't get him here we go again
here we go again here we go again
oh yes oh yes oh yes yes yes good god oh
my god oh [ __ ] just - oh my god [ __ ] god
damn it uh [ __ ] me oh my god
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] good [ __ ]
god
if I can't [ __ ] see anything how am I
supposed to be able to dodge anything
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] oh you oh you
[ __ ] oh my god not this [ __ ] No
goddamnit okay what did I do
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
I don't know what you want from me oh
you [ __ ] [ __ ] come on oh and I'm
that's done God Wow God
oh just let go so hard [ __ ] this [ __ ]
that's such a [ __ ] stupid boss if I
can't [ __ ] see how can I win I'm just
gonna go to the [ __ ] basic level get
some goddamn lives because Jesus Christ
like honestly what the [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] stupid so [ __ ] stupid this
stupidest goddamn thing I've ever seen
in my life
god dammit are you far are you [ __ ]
serious really I gotta go through a
third [ __ ] phase
oh my god oh my god oh my [ __ ] god
oh I can't see
what a waste of [ __ ] time my god oh
my god oh my god I'm so mad I'm so
unbelievably mad all right here's
another boss I don't know what this one
is oh [ __ ] oh god [ __ ] this [ __ ]
or that or [ __ ] that 14 lives to go
into a boss have never oh my god hi
hello how are you doing my name is
markiplier yes oh don't tell me that
[ __ ]
I don't want to know it okay I didn't
want to know what that was no this one's
mine
this one's my oh wow
why okay I don't need any of this oh I
get it I get it
okay well holy [ __ ]
tonight where am i oh my god
and she's broken you [ __ ] kidding me
are you kidding are you [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] kidding me it bugged out [ __ ]
bugged out I'm done I'm walking away
from this I'm done I cannot do this I
can't do this I just can't do this I
can't I can't [ __ ] do it
you're halfway through [ __ ] you I'm
halfway through [ __ ] you I'm done
this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ] this
is a hundred percent [ __ ] half of
the time I'm trying to control my
goddamn character it doesn't work
yeah well that's it I'm done with this
this has been puss I've been playing
this for about two and a half hours and
that is just about enough for me the
games good that's the thing that's
surreal and I love it and like I love
the aesthetics of it but it's just got
these if you're gonna have a bullet hell
that is this nuanced and this like tight
controls and mechanics you cannot you
absolutely cannot lose control the
character ever I can the whole fact that
I have to click and hold him down and
when I die I have to reek lick or
sometimes I don't have to reek lick and
it's just this I didn't want to go
[ __ ] there but I'm done [ __ ] you just
there's no main menu thing there's no
nope just this had a bunch of different
avatars didn't even know about that but
that would have been cool to know but no
it's fine this game is good but man does
it have some flaws it really really has
some serious flaws there's no way that
you can have something this tight that
doesn't work half the time you
can't do it you cannot blind me after I
get hit and then I don't know where I am
and then I just get hit again like it'd
be fine if I was still moving after I
got hit and it was one of those things
where I got hit and it was like oh like
maybe even no invulnerability like half
a second and it's just like keep going
but the fact that my character stops is
just so unbelievably unfair and then
that last boss is being broken that's
that is what it is so I suffered through
this hard I suffered through it very
hard I did great for I'm I'm I'm saying
I did great and I did do great I did
great but I'm done so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play puss for yourself and put
you through some horrible horrible stuff
click the link in the description below
and you will have a good time but other
than that it is a cool game I love the
aesthetics of it but it's just like too
much too much too much too much too much
too much too much to be fun anyway thank
you everybody so much for being a PI
welcome back to Poulos um this is
actually the same part I am just coming
back to it from another day so today I
was looking at the news of this game and
apparently they've put out a patch that
addressed some of the bugs that I was
encountering so I wanted to give this
game another try another honest try to
see if it was something that I could
actually wrap my head around now so I'm
gonna give it again I've taken some time
away I'm not as pissed off as I was and
I'm just gonna try to enjoy it but I did
change my avatar to something that was a
bit more representative of my mood well
my angry kitten seems to be working I'm
not sure like it's it's gonna be very
difficult for me to discern like whether
or not something is fixed or not I mean
honestly how would I be able to tell but
if it is then I just will be able to
beat it I guess so give me a second to
get back to where I was
I still don't expect it to be easy but
if it's manageable which the other one
didn't seem to be then I'll be much
happier at least I haven't regrets
completely for my skill set I mean also
my wrist isn't hurting me which it was
before
yi-yi-yi yeah yeah yeah easy-peasy
easy-peasy easy-peasy okay I'll be back
when I get to the boss you guys worries
at least I remember these levels that's
that's pretty much all I can really say
about it right now things do lose their
charm once you've died to them ten
bajillion times oh god damn it
Oh Oh God why is what now my mouse
doesn't stay in the game
why what why would it not why would my
mouse nest oh oh oh God they've made it
worse they've somehow made it worse
because just imagine I'm in a boss fight
and my mouse goes out of the screen
after I'm dying and I'm trying to get
back in and but my mouse is off-screen
and then I click outside the window and
then I die again
see right there right there I just
clicked outside the goddamn window when
I Oh how'd they make it worse how did
they make it worse all right let's see
how this goes I guess here comes the
boss it's not gonna go well yeah if here
he comes alright and let's see if this
is gonna be any better
probably not all things considered all
right here we go
oh [ __ ] oh they really got me that time
okay that's a little better because now
I don't have to click miss me that's me
okay now I'm in this phase
ah [ __ ] didn't get them all I tried but
I'm doing a lot better he's a far cry
better than whoa what the [ __ ] okay
thank you for more immunity by the by
that is definitely more immunity than it
was it was marginally less stupid than
it was there we go okay this is actually
better it was not better before but this
is actually better shockingly it is
somehow better oh [ __ ] god damn it oh I
almost had that okay well now I got
these [ __ ] to deal with it really is
beneficial to get that in one phase
oh [ __ ] god damn it yeah the longer
immunity is just an absolute must I
think that was the biggest pain in the
dick okay this is actually this might be
manageable ass [ __ ] you're not gonna
give me another fist face okay there we
go
it tries again okay just gotta get you
and that was it okay get this [ __ ] Oh
get your [ __ ] slapped that felt good it
felt good look at your [ __ ] up fit I
can't move okay well okay there we go
I guess now I got it well wasted a life
but yeah you stupid [ __ ] you stupid
piece of garbage you value you thought
you could get the best of me yeah yeah
look at your stupid face
that's okay oh can i oh it did the thing
that I said it was gonna do [ __ ]
Christ can you use give me another fist
pounding please I I hate that I have to
ask for that outright but if you could
just give me another fist pounding
that'd be great
just pound me there we go give me in
there all right I'm gonna try to get
these all in one go this time okay who's
got this I got this
that's right me I've got this okay that
doesn't help nobody there we go that
helps me okay someone pick me up someone
pick come on come on baby come on baby
there we go a little more speed would be
great
where you gonna go where you gonna go
yeah yeah yeah that's good no that's not
good this good does want to eat it's
gonna go oh [ __ ] come on come on come on
oh I've got two more come on I can make
this oh [ __ ] me come on oh please
there we go ah whoa so close goddamnit
if I don't get this in this next go I'm
gonna be sold my head oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay that's fine
made that just give me a goddamn
pounding okay pound me no not like that
god dammit ah [ __ ]
just Oh God really you missed [ __ ] come
on
doh come on No Oh oh my god just [ __ ]
pounded reve reve alright last one I'm
gonna get you so good you're gonna get
got okay I just need to wait for the
slow Crawley boy this guy right here
he's gonna slow crawl right where I need
to be and then I've got this guy in the
[ __ ] bag Oh get ready to be well get
your [ __ ] slapping oh [ __ ] [ __ ] slap
you slap get slapped that's right
[Music]
well maybe if you didn't suck so much
ass now I'm not human I guess that's one
answer oh it got us thank you for the
key huh oh yeah sure okay thank you
don't call me that Joe call me call me
that louder all right well well damn I
uh I did it
shockingly I did it it was marginally
better oh oh oh god oh god I was not
ready for this okay I didn't know I get
this at at the end of every level so
that no we'll never mind that I guess
I'm not gonna have any benefit out of
that that's wonderful okay well do I
keep going now or what I think this is
gonna die again all right let's try it
if I die even once I'm done but if I if
I get this and I'm able to beat this
boss - then I'm gonna keep going alright
back in the fourth e oh well I'm a
dumbass what [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I don't
know what icarus does I'm not arms
insurer but hopefully Icarus isn't just
a complete useless waste of my life cuz
servant for the entirety of my life is a
long time hopefully maybe it's not a
long time at honestly who knows okay
this is going smoothly this is going way
too smoothly honestly I'm just bracing
for when it goes horribly wrong which it
will halfway through already is it's
going real good
I swear that it didn't used to be like
this where I can just click on it and
then let go because if it was like that
before and I just wasn't doing that then
I hate myself it's the only answer I
have to that if it if it was if it was
like this before because I swear I've
tried to do this and it just was not
working
[Music]
- oh thank you time wizard
okay well I'm all off
well [ __ ] men oh okay oh well I'm out I
knew it was gonna go bad at some point
then there went bad all right boss Tom
balsam good number of lives not as much
as I would want but good number of lives
I'll remember this boss at all oh ah
this is the one where I got stuck on not
terribly the worst but just like I got
stuck oh well there's my loop all right
where am i can i okay there we go oh
[ __ ] Oh [ __ ] Christ
okay great please do not do that
repetitiously just please that's all I
ask
oh oh oh okay well that's something
so the trick of this guy is just like
he's hitting himself so quit hitting
yourself you stupid fool okay if I could
stop dying too easy [ __ ] oh my god oh my
god oh my god I cannot see oh I can't
see [ __ ]
whoa it's just a wall I can't okay I
guess that was it then he he got stuck
but this time he just killed him
Oh Oh baby I'm angry but you know hi
there hi oh I'm an angry Kid this is
going shockingly well all the sudden
mm-hmm
I guess now I get chance for lives so
that's that's nice oh crap well I'm not
gonna get any lives cuz I'm not able to
actually hit any oh god why am I not
hitting anything
ah well [ __ ] got one more that's all
that really matters okay lock them
unlock them lock the lock um lick'em
welcome give them turducken okay there
we go
and in okay is this the last levels
entering okay this looks awful okay
think I go this way I'm not a hundred
percent sure but okay I think what the
[ __ ] really
oh well joke's on me for going for that
but that was interesting that must be
the new Kitty's doing whoa oh did not
see those coming okay this is gonna be a
[ __ ] to go down here okay safe here and
then okay I think miss Kitka Piske get a
new high score and that's real good oh I
mean oh well this looks unfriendly I
mean it's not too too hard but just
collectively it's a little stressful a
little stressful but again doing
relative what am I looking at I don't X
I'm not gonna look at it too closely
because I if I do I'll die so I'm not
gonna look at it
okay I'm having trouble understanding
this
yeah let's slow this down please thank
you oh thank you that was lovely just
what the doctor ordered
thank goodness for that that bad was
good that was very helpful very helpful
what's the deep top I think that's a bug
yep I'm almost positive that's a bug
that's the timer thing and it's super
bugged
yeah that's not supposed to happen I'm
I'm percent certain now it's just this
ticking time bomb that's just making me
stressed I better no nope still there
okay and I die there oh no please do not
tell me it's gonna be a boss run is it
really gonna be a boss run are you
really honestly gonna make me go through
every boss again in a row
you better not please tell me you're not
doing that Oh what is that I don't I
don't know what that is
what is Oh God Oh No
okay well oh boy okay well this isn't
the worst thing in the world
uh-huh uh-huh oh well taught me once
fool me once fool me toos fool me Deus I
don't know Who am I have I missed one
oh I see okay I get it
of course
everything's shaking which is so good
for being able to see where I'm going
alright here we go
I have no idea what this boss is like I
have no idea but it's probably gonna be
really freaking difficult okay here we
go here we go here we go here we go
okay hello hi go oh okay
you got it but where's your God now
meow I don't know look I'm yelling up a
storm
alright let's just do it one of these
was was it supposed to be what am i
doing what am i doing am I supposed to
bomb something okay I don't know what
I'm doing but okay whatever
oh boy hello friend Oh what are you
doing oh that's easy enough I guess oh
[ __ ] didn't even see those oh my god
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay
ahh god dammit I was going for the
stupid time slower I mean they must be
giving me tons of time slow for a reason
cuz otherwise you know what else would I
do with my life
whoa hey buddy please get those out of
here okay so far so not bad there's
something off to the left with a health
bar he's supposed to do probably throw a
bomb at it or something you might guess
anyway
ah there we go oh man these are hard to
see Hey look away it's the unicorn over
there what's the unicorn doing
oh it's helping me with the time that's
right it's the time the unicorn gives
the time I mean that's very helpful very
helpful I just feel like they're gonna
take it away from me when I needed the
most which is gonna really suck no not
there what the [ __ ] okay yeah all right
give me a bomb
give me a bam there's the Bam's here's
the delecious Bam's get that over there
whoa [ __ ] come on man dad
Oh kitty cat with the hearts that's what
you give me right if I remember
correctly not that this is gonna do
anything just yet but I wanted to push
it over there because I'm OCD like that
I just wanted it to be nice and oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
okay Bam's I like grams kitty can you
give me a heart give me a sweet life
that'd be nice again that doesn't really
help me oh I guess it's not supposed to
help me considering that they're bombs
probably you know like like Bowser
throwing his ticky tacky things it
doesn't really want you to use them
against him but you know that's just the
eventualities of what happens because
he's stupid and this goat guys pretty
dumb poo okay here we go here we go wait
when he's a little slow down the time
getting my clock set a little bit more
less stupid yeah well I did a priest
open anyway oh no he's dead okay I did
it just right Jesus Jesus is here boy oh
[ __ ] everything's gonna be okay Jesus
has arrived oh [ __ ] Oh Oh God that
didn't he'll be a nil oh this is a
pattern okay I just can't really uh
patterns just hard to see okay pattern
pattern pattern pattern it is a pattern
it's a patterns it's just two spiraling
oh it's two spirals uh whatever
well Jesus are you gonna help or not
it's kind of like a Satanist thing here
maybe you should you know do something
about that seems like your territory
more than anything I can't see [ __ ] okay
you better give me some to Bhama
do this the saying really you some to
buy I'm also kitty cat what are you
doing can you help her what Oh shot
goddammit well I'm just bleeding lives
now like a fool oh [ __ ] like a fool I am
give me so there we go okay there we go
give me this I'm gonna bomb you with all
four do [ __ ] why did that not last that
didn't last long at all
come on don't suck it don't suck it
don't suck I sucked it
well dolphin man's here so that's good I
guess ten lives left I got one more
kitty cat to blow up kitty cat cultists
to blow up oh well that I don't think
that was [ __ ] come on give me two
like the area's darius darius darius
darius now we're gonna get aldo bamos
all the bing bang bomb boomers oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh we come it's time we
must win okay transform you say trance
yeah
transform Jesus by the power of Jesus
[Laughter]
alright okay alright okay okay I see you
okay alright okay alright I get you I'm
seeing what I'm picking up what you're
putting down I'm picking it up form of
oh whoa
I love the spiral out into existence yes
beautiful now you're gonna get slapped I
don't care if you are goat or the devil
you're gonna get slapped oh [ __ ] oh
you're getting so slapped I don't know
what I'm supposed to be oh my suppose a
dodge in any way shape or form that's
something I should be doing I guess I
guess oh [ __ ] I don't know what oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] no [ __ ] no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh god no [ __ ] no jeez
ohms oh thank you I don't know when I
got that but I hid these things got damn
just hit him
oh my god okay here we go here we go
here we go can I get on can can our
powers combine to be a little more
useful you know what I mean they're just
a little bit lackluster get rekt goat
man oh you're gonna put up your shield
again aren't you yeah you are don't act
like you're not
whoa wasn't gonna BAM you're done so
you're done so ones oh you're done Z one
Z Z oh yeah finishing blow baby oh baby
oh yeah hi
Oh
but I think that's very professional doc
is this like the the beginning of the
animal with Bob not Brendan Fraser but
you know who Oh
Cerberus Wow the best creation Wow
the mothership yep that was a vagina
yeah that was if I didn't even connect
the mother ship thing that was just a
big ol floating vagina or uterus sorry
uterus none of a Chinese uterus Subaru
jackpot see mistress yeah I didn't
notice your tentacles Bahamut vomit
bottom it got wrecked
Icarus oh it's nice baby real nice
chronic horn cronic horn-like Chronos
for time Jay good old JC man to see Rick
to fish oh hell yeah just a normal fish
princess oh look at Prince go push and
push and a boy we had a boy go get him
push you got him yeah you got him made
by team coil that was really well done
and the patch it despite me clicking out
of the screen fixed a lot of my
grievances I didn't run into nearly as
many problems there wasn't the problems
of dying repeatedly to a boss I was
actually able to like dodge things
properly it made sense it worked out
well I don't know what they changed with
the going outside the screen but it
worked for everything else so that was
much better much tighter much better
controls I like that that was good and
you obviously can see that there was a
change because I went from dying
repeatedly to one shotting every boss I
didn't lose a single time this whole
time I mean I died of course but I
didn't lose game over so that was good
boost loves me oh I don't puss loves me
oh thank you so much close alright and
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for putting up with my anger I
know this is a long let's play but hey I
like doing that sometimes I want to
finish a game on one video occasionally
makes for a more interesting and
well-rounded experience I'd say so thank
you everybody so much for watching
and oh we don't have to go through this
again we're good I didn't even get a
score for that so thank you for that
thank you everybody so much for watching
and if you didn't know already there is
a way you can help me make cool projects
in the future if you look down just
below this video you'll see a big join
button by the subscribe button where you
can click on and help support cool
projects like Wilfred mother love and
Wharf stash in the future you'll also
get some perks for doing it so please
look at it see what you get and see if
it's worth it for you thank you
everybody that has and thank you
everybody the will and thank you
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in next video
bye bye
[Music]